you
hi everyone it's Jerry I am on Leach s
org and I'm gonna play a 15-10 game
I am paired up against a little Plotkin
so it's been a bit since I did one of
these let's put up on duo in there and
see what happens okay
I'm gonna go with Knight f3 we've played
quite a bit myself in little Plotkin
probably bullit most for the most part
some 960 games actually okay well this
is this is pretty interesting because
just before I started recording here I
was reviewing some alpha0 games so we're
gonna go into alpha zero style and go
for a fee and keto okay yeah this is
actually pretty interesting that we have
this opening on board so just going with
a fiend keto and I'll give a shot with
this gambit line if allowed in the alpha
zero games there are several where d5 is
in there
and basically pitch the pond okay now
this is different now there is another
okay I'm not gonna go with d5 now for
one there is another alpha zero came
though that goes night-night c3 and then
shooting for a quickie for a five I
think I titled that I covered that video
and I titled it alpha zero in the golden
Knight
could be off with that one or no was
alpha zero in the connected passed pawn
yeah um so I think I think I want to go
with Knight c3 here what else to
consider I do have a little bit more
time compared to previous videos I think
everything else was about five second
increment so I'm just thinking Knight c3
castles what's the difference I can't
stop d5 so I mean I'm expecting Knight
c3 d5 straightaway
what I want to get in the get in the
position I'm trying to establish here is
93 E 4 and then e 5 its what alpha 0 did
but I don't think I could do this with
the the move order selected I think it's
one move short I think Bishop e7 was
played before c6
is this not going to go anywhere besides
c3 I don't think so
a castle after all that in a castle keep
the option open to maybe support c4 with
my queen night on d2 now this is one of
the more sensitive squares when you make
the decision to fianchetto c4 is a very
sensitive point similarly you could have
situations where when the Queen Bishop
Fein caddos f4 would be vulnerable
just kind of see some just map it out
there anyhow I have to take some care
over c4 and I think maybe even b3 here
I'm not sure I want to commit my knight
just yet and I don't know where I want
to go with my bishop I know what going
to g5 that tension is quickly resolved
Bishop f4 I could consider Bishop f4
f 4 and then 9 2 D 2
before in a capture I could just play
night here and pick up the pawn next
let's give this a shot
put the Bishop on f4 no I'll be welcome
with the dark square Bishop exchange if
black goes for that okay yeah I think
I'm gonna go forward with this
so Knight B to d2 it is
I guess this night could be slightly
you're irritating to my bishop but after
Bishop III I guess the knight has
nothing better than to return
so I'm just thinking about rook c1 any
other candidate move here
I can't consider jumping right in yeah
let's start with a guaranteed productive
move okay to c1 the C file will open up
one way or the other and already well
Knight to e5 is really the only thing
that I have on my mind
ninety-five
yeah let's put the knight in the center
okay
so my bishop can see the world I'm happy
about that that was one of the main
points I want to make sure my knight is
out of its way I have a bit more control
over for now can't allow this and ibut
this Bishop to be captured so this
decision should be pretty quick
maybe e4 to be a bit careful with my
clean trying to do something that feels
active at first glance capture and then
I have to be careful how I recapture may
end up in a fork putting my queen on any
for very sensible move rook to c8 is now
the time to play e4
or maybe just capture that is also a
possibility in fact if I capture and
black recaptures with a C pawn C file is
completely opened and the structures
symmetrical maybe then I feel a bit more
confident about Queen a4 although
chop-chop Queen a4 I think a6 is fine
and then I'm running into B 596 Knight
c4 no thanks
well this is a dumb piece on d2 I could
try to improve it what happens after
efore actually I don't know I mean I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this though I I think
I like this move just gonna try and
overtake the d5 point I believe the epon
should not be captured because my
bishops eyes will remain open okay now
this is different I have an opportunity
to play e5 and in the alpha zero games
loves e5 but I don't want to just do it
because alpha zero did I want to have
some reason behind it of course
it would certainly have an impact on the
night on the bishop this night would be
demoted this Bishop would be a bit more
limited the squares I control pawn on e5
my bishops eyes would be shut I really
want that
'if I've
and uh well it makes for an interesting
structure huh let's maybe learn
something I'm not familiar with this
structure I think this is a fine move so
let's just maybe learn something here
now that on the other hand I was
expecting night here well I feel like
with this night I could try to do
something where I play against this guy
what is that exactly
all for starters uh I don't think I want
to see I have some interesting ideas be
a little bit careful I was thinking c5
chop chop
but then there's maybe g4 Bishop here
and then d4 my bishop dead maybe dead
option is to simply capture and I don't
think black can afford to capture like
this because then I would have a four
versus three on the kingside move my
bishop and rush this pawn up to f5 so if
I take I'm pretty sure this must happen
maybe I'll be quick to occupy the C file
in that position
I feel like this night is going to
struggle
the other thing if I if I don't make
this capture maybe black takes and then
gets a nice square for the night um at
the 8 minute mark maybe I just go ahead
and capture on d5 what other candidate
move I'm not really seeing another
candidate move
I could try and keep the tension for no
I think I want to just try and play
against this night yeah let's do that
okay
he expected recapture with the C pawn
okay well I was thinking Bishop here
hmm a bishop might get a little bit
active here might this be too
far-fetched of a plan trying to run my F
pawn up there maybe I shouldn't try to
do too much maybe my plan should be to
try and shut down this Bishop trying to
trying to control it and trying to do
too much here the knight I feel is going
struggle and this bishop next mm-hmm I
don't want that bishop to have an easy
time playing let's start with the Queen
here
is a 6 b5 idea I was scared of earlier
when the night was on d7 and I had fear
of it's sinking into c4 if a six then
I'm happy in that I no longer have to
worry about Bishop a6 and it activating
so I can't stop b5 I think I just want
to immediately relocate I am opposite
the bishop that's unprotected and so if
a b6 move is there also this queen is
now restricted to defending b6 so if B 5
I could think about a 4 where's this
night going I don't know I think I want
to take the rook no okay
this Knight this this Knight is a real
dummy this is a weak square with blacks
last move maybe I don't play a 4 I think
I want to I want to operate on this week
square how can I do this clean here
night here something like this is not
know I don't know if it's really
far-fetched I think I want my night on
b3
now let's start with this here's the
other thing
I work on c4 could be pretty irritating
so I want to keep in mind to b3 where's
the night going here and then here well
the row can't go here so I have an
opportunity for this feels really good
to do something like that
hmm I have time to get that in that
would be really nice
well I would get a passed pawn so if
yeah well let's let's jump in here
be ok if I give black a passed pawn
because when I capture here I have a
passed pawn as well and I'm still
playing with this space I have to be on
the lookout for g5 but ok my bishop is
fine as a square trying to play ok yeah
yeah the Knights and he definitely wants
to square to tell you why I'm gonna jump
right in
and this is primarily against the knight
I do not want the night to even step
foot there it's not one of those cases
where okay when the night is unsafe or
then I give it a kick no I just don't
want the night to arrive there period I
think I'm I think I'm strategically
winning because this bishop in this
night I think I'm suffocating these
pieces and I don't want to trade too
much playing now with some space I want
to keep more pieces on so that's why I'm
opting for pawn takes instead of rook
takes
this must be winning for me I don't see
how these pieces ever get productive
before we both have connected passed
pawns but I'm playing with space okay
and I may want to grab some more well
first things first I might want to just
stop this pawn sack it's clean here I'm
gonna step up the other thought I had
was this my opponents playing too fast
well let's get my h-bond playing these
these forward moves by the night are all
negated by blacks pawns there's some
activity like this possibly but my queen
is a really dominant piece
okay
this rook is a dummy
and my opponent and with of them without
the bishop around I can try and show
that this bishop is pretty beastly yeah
so let's do this I could go in for
something like this you know bishops
both bearing down towards the king let
me give that a go
okay well one thing I like is that I
could back up with tempo now against the
rook let's do that not afraid of one
piece it's just if black can go ahead
and connect another piece with that rook
maybe that's a different story
I think I just back up now
yeah but the rook there think rook here
is necessary
stop Queen d3 but I could insist on it
rook c3 and then Queen here how is how
is this as this being stopped let's find
out I'm going to go forward with it
now these black may want to just take
and then play here but I'm pretty quick
to slither on in there let's see
opponent has more time than started with
two squares and there isn't this
convenient way to shut down this
diagonal because of the pressure I have
against h6 okay so this is the idea now
so after Queen here you could play this
and you're not dropping this pawn
however suppose I prep it first with h5
yeah just play h5
now there isn't g6 and I'm ready to go
to one of these two don't know if it
really matters all that I didn't
consider that move at all
Wow very nice
okay let's not let's not panic
I want to make sure this doesn't even
hit so let's start with this it's not
Russia Queen d3 queen GA
I could have considered maybe doing that
first and then after Queen here then
going to d4
okay
I wouldn't mind getting this rook off
hmm
what about attacking this this rook with
my bishop
we're worth a truck bill now let's do
this you go with some regrouping 406 I
want to have this option that you know
if black ever tries to get active on the
a file I just go here force the Queen
back
you know think I want to release the
pressure against this pond there is
there are two pieces could strike there
so let's step up with this Bishop
I want to keep this around as my king
shelter yeah I could put both bishops
here and all these squares would be
covered from the rook entering let's try
that let's uh I had to get some faster
moves in
I'm in a position where I could try
something like this maybe my king is a
bit more safe on this square let's go
with this off the back rank
going here cuz I want to be able to move
my Queen and black I think given an
opportunity is gonna push this pawn this
is the only pawn break I have to worry
about but I wouldn't mind seeing it open
up a little bit more
maybe there was something better than
king here I liked that I could return
here with check if I want tell you well
maybe maybe we just negate this f6 pawn
break all together everything is covered
here from the rook knight here would
just block things out so still black is
playing without the minor pieces
I mean if I had more time I'm pretty
sure I would find a correct plan here
okay
prepping f6 maybe this rook up and over
why not let's give that a shot
how's this Knight ever gonna get going
to get active here here no here he's
dead like wherever he goes here the
pawns kill him black pawns kill him and
here my pawn kills him
this Bishop stuck behind this pun always
has to watch out for this I'm forgetting
that I even have this guy around
rooks rooks rook here let's let's put
some pressure
you
mm-hm
well I'm gonna go here so now I'm less
fearful of this so the Queen tries to
get active I'm just not gonna allow I'm
gonna go back home this was my idea I
expected that move to be pulled off in a
blink now this bishops gonna hit here
and this rook has a responsibility just
want to keep black out of my house yeah
returns so maybe maybe I could return
here have my bishop be the one that
makes sure this pawn doesn't budge I'm
giving up this square but my queen could
Wow okay I was not expecting that that
cannot be good
I'm gonna get this here's the other
thing hmm
well Wow okay I could take on Poisson
chopped how I was black going to defend
this dark square
chop-chop hear hear hear hear
my bishop will find something productive
to do okay I think everything is just
pointing at open the position up for the
bishops
taking with upon so the rook has lateral
movement I mean I could start thinking
about exchange sacrifices here this is
probably a move as well
hmm let's see you know taking with a
pawn well there is the rook that could
defend okay okay this Bishop is a dummy
but how about this move
looking at this know if I want to allow
the trades now let's go here stopping a
rook f7 threatening that oh just came
there
let's pull the bishop back I'm really
thinking about putting putting the rook
here
I still have a passer would I be winning
if all major pieces are off bishop pair
ending I want to get at the king though
suppose I do this threatening this pawn
threatening this poem think I like that
move
hmm
Herk takes
I could yeah if I do all that I don't
want to bring it to that point though we
gotta go faster
striking here now
yeah a strategy to put pressure on me on
the clock is is he's working don't know
it's getting down to the wire here I'm
glad there's the ten seconds increment
if g5 chop-chop
f4 am I not not going to win that on
also recaps six
ix takes pawn takes rook takes mm-hmm
don't think I could take advantage of
that pin Queen takes pawn Queen takes
pawn pawn takes rook Queen takes bishop
that's got to be good these
checks as well I'm gonna give this a go
I have not calculated it all but allow a
pawn takes rook yeah now does this check
anything I think I want to keep that in
my back pocket all right I'm gonna take
with the pawn I don't want to see the
king move with the discovered check
against my king
so now there's no more bloc hater of my
pasture as long as my king is safe I'm
pretty sure up should be winning this
Knight is a long way off from posing any
danger to my king
everything is just opened here 14 black
King here I could pick off this pawn got
two passers black has a passer but
that's realizing that Layton's because
it's not really a factor
so let's see capture here I have an easy
reply just to recap sure King they're
preparing to run Queen takes pawn is a
blunder you want to take here it is with
check but now I'm opening up a file for
my king
or about
like here possibly
I have I have this square covered by the
bishop maybe I should just take that
push here look here share check
I gotta I gotta do something quick I
feel like the king is slipping away a
little bit
once the material count and I'm not down
any material the night will be
recapturing and try and control the
Queen
oof I want to do this support my bishop
covering still a lot of ground from the
Queen but this has gotten out of control
it's sharpening up
and stuff
you
threat here z6 maybe I could do that
what I do Unruh have three rook f3 III
still bishops are covering quite up for
a lot of ground
I try for that I keep my queen in a
position where it gives checks this must
be the right way forward
than this if the rook isn't guarding l5
to watch for this file
covered
yeah where does the rook go one of these
two possibly
rook F 1 here Knight up 6 maybe I I bolt
or with this pawn as well
or actually I think I want my king here
off of this file avoiding those checks
and maybe then I'm ready to slip in here
maybe I shouldn't be too fast to rush
with this pawn control the night
rook here trying for this
No okay that ah let's let's do this move
mm-hmm let's go right here
okay yeah it's getting kind of tricky
step up here and check
I think you have to try this
hmm
you
scary it's definitely scary
let's get this pond wrong actually I'm
covering this now I can't push this pond
though because of this pressure here
tonight is still under control I have
this square covered
very interesting game
keep there's these squares under control
from the Queen checks
if this proof either major piece the
releases pressure of this Bishop I could
consider this
zooks well where does it where's the
Queen go is the knight move Maybach oh
oh oh I'm just saying I have this move
here and then I have a nice check
possibly I think I want to let this
connected pass pawn bolt okay I'm glad I
at least spotted that there's a no there
is no check I got that covered my pieces
are guarding a lot of the checking
squares I like that I have this in this
is a nice configuration to have okay
clean there I not give some checks now
and give this check next I'm winning
this check first King has to go here and
then I pick off the Queen let's do it
okay
clean here check am I missing anything
don't think so
[Music]
playing this one out I guess to me do it
is there me I have 20 seconds to find I
could always just get the Queen there's
no fancy steel Knights
okay I'm just picking up the Queen
there's I'm sure there was a mate there
there's no stalemates yeah they just
resigned wow I guess reviewing those
alpha0 games just before this game kind
of helped I was in this mentality to
just kind of restrict pieces alpha0 has
a tendency to do that in all the games
we've seen one way or the other
and oftentimes it was related to the
LightSquared Bishop and I kind of
managed to do that in this one
all right gee a quick GG and before I
stare at it with the engine yeah I mean
I spent a lot of time here
with uh you know castles or 9c3 I just
can't really remember the move order I
think maybe this was in and then castles
I'm sorry this was in and then after
night C 3 C 6 and then e 4 and after D v
e5 was in there it's just a move off you
know I'm glad that kind of experimented
some with this this pawn on e5 this
structure
I felt that maybe 97 is a better move we
could look at that briefly once I dive
into the analysis 97 with the idea of
supporting c5 so okay I got up on an e5
and you know it kind of starts to get
very strategic and I think I think I'm
just winning from here wouldn't be
surprised to see the graph always in my
favor from this point on maybe even
after uh after this move it's quite
difficult for black because these these
guys just never got active so and I
probably should have had a quicker
knockout I had had plenty of time to
establish this kind of grip over the
Kings side the space on the Kings side
to neutralize the rook and I probably
could have done something different
after this g5 move again I was already
thinking about rook here stuff I think I
made a right decision here to capture on
e6
you know well I'll have a look at that
and I did had to be a little bit careful
but these guys cover a lot of ground I
don't think I gave like any
opportunities here was easy to go wrong
this might be some Zook swung position
yeah
what's the night to once the Queen do
eyes are just pointing out if either of
these move then I could push this pawn
this guy's eyes are opened and I think
I'm then looking to get into the h6
square but okay let's looking at the
analysis here see what it has to say I
clicked on it
okay maybe I just need to refresh it
should be running hmm wonder why there's
not a computer analysis isn't going
hmm not sure maybe somebody Artie there
are some spectators here so maybe
somebody clicked on it and it's it's
crunching the numbers right now but it's
still showing requests a computer
analysis button for me okay but I could
still flick this on and see what
stockfish has to say going through this
one so yeah again kind of kind of funny
that this happened reviewing alpha0
games and we go right into pretty much
the main opening that we saw in the
alpha zero games Queen's Indian defense
we're in all those games that we saw
alpha0 was playing with white now this
game that I'm trying I was trying to
recall I believe it was Bishop e7 knight
c6 and then after c6 e for so I just I
just want to highlight this variation
this is this is basically what happened
castles about Bishop here
[Music]
how did this go exactly oh no no it was
this actually the bishop gave a check
Bishop d2 and then the bishop returned
and then Knight c3 and after this this
this pawn is here Knight is here castles
the bishop returns
was the star well not quite the star
movie ab3 chop-chop and after takes this
was this this was the move as what a
stock fish nine saying yeah stock 49
suggest before but just this idea i
titled that video if you haven't seen it
alpha 0 and the protected pass bone
currently white is down upon and it's a
big pond but the deeper point is that
there's some space on the kingside and
the bishop that's kind of hemmed in so
okay we didn't we didn't get in that
position here but that's what I was
trying to recall during the game but the
the moves weren't just right so Bishop
f4
ninety-two about analysis working and do
another refresh I don't know why there's
a there we go so that's how it's looking
all right so there wasn't there wasn't
there wasn't an opportunity for black
once I had an advantage which was at the
e5 point go figure
throw up on on e5 and everything is is
wonderful no but where is it maybe a
tiny bit better for team black after I
play Bishop takes e5 hmm yeah Knight
takes g4 or Knight not Knight takes g4
but Knight g4 and then after this g5 oh
okay I have to be very careful now if
Knight g4 I can't back up
because of this very weakening but yeah
this lashing out move and I don't want
to go here and there's a suggestion to
take here okay that certainly has its
points so let's just say there's a
recapture oh then I have a square at
least so far there's that as a recapture
oh okay then things get really sharp
okay yeah this is a super committal move
that would black would have to crunch
the numbers on that for sure but made
the more natural move Knight to d7 I
back up i Goti foreign it does like e4
and it suggests black go ahead and take
one of these - no it's it's leaning more
towards this now in the game I was
saying that maybe this was the better
decision to not have my bishops eyes
open so easily
but certainly improving a poor minor
piece my night would be happy about
recapturing their oh yeah and then I
could function on the d6 square I start
to coordinate well and after this
capture all I could do similar but I
guess I'm not establishing upon on e5 in
this variation and there's the move c5
now very thematic open the bishops eyes
strike at the center
black did none of the above in this one
and once I got e5 and I guess things are
are looking pretty good from here on out
had it's a controlled position does the
like Queen to a4 I likes Queen a4 and
wants to exchange rooks I don't know I'm
not sure what exactly is gained by
exchanging the rooks I know if the
bishop had to recapture on c8 that would
be some success the bishops demoted
but whether the queen is on the home
square c8 I don't think it's an
inconvenience for a buck I don't know I
just I thought keeping the tension was
fine
and now cleaned III rook takes c8 again
queen d3 it's bouncing back and forth I
went with Queen to d3 and I think this
is this is the way you have to do it
well maybe that's a bit too strong I
think this is very logical black just
gave me a square to work with so let's
let's point some pieces there so night
b3 to c5 it is and this just as it turns
out he's never gonna get to see four
especially after I'm recapturing with
upon
and again I want to keep pieces on so I
want to keep majors on playing with the
space so structure change it's just a
controlled position in that protected
past pawn video that's kind of I wasn't
I wasn't saying it during the game but
we have this kind of this kind of stuff
with the bishops repositioning and doing
good job controlling many of the defiled
squares actually the D file was
completely opened or eventually became
opened but yeah and in play and suit on
the on the King side and it kind of went
in that path in this game I just had to
watch for little things I really got to
express a lot in this game while I was
playing
that's why I'm kind of a zipper through
this post game analysis it's controlled
position these guys just are not playing
and I just want to see how I could have
maybe approached this a little bit
different once g5 was in what is it
saying here maybe I didn't do too bad
then
I didn't it didn't really go down much
after that so maybe I approached it okay
I captured that it feels like that's
just it's gotta be the right way forward
I don't think I mean capturing here
helps out one of blacks pieces the rook
has some nice lateral movement but there
are so many other positives that I get
by capturing it's the bishop pair these
pawns are now further away from the king
he's not as comfortable and just just
targets now and this is the other thing
he six becomes a target and sure enough
in the game it fell I won't know yeah I
actually want to question that at that
point in the game this this appears to
be alright
yes I'm happy about this now not sure
how much time I devoted this one yeah
about about a half a minute
but in the end I guess it was a best
move here Queen take c6
and Queens just getting really active
and you know
threatening to go here with
pick up the pawn next with check coin h4
gonna have this possibility available
and yeah I realized this a bit too late
so I could I could take off with c6
thing was only once my King was here and
I had this Bishop and pawn structure
that I that I realized no I have the c6
move realized that a bit too late
but I kept control here Bishop f5
cleanup for check back to Bishop f5 hmm
I guess I hit at some good moves here
along the way so I'm happy about that
in G for Queen F for ya and something
something else needs to be done here
clearly instead of queen they're tough
moves to make right King to g8 rook to
c1 releasing pressure against the bishop
not tough to
no-no-no you want to keep pressure on
your opponent's position so you can see
why you would want not want to consider
a move like rook to c1 it's not like
you're eyeing up an additional check
so if Brooke to see one in this position
what could I do
Oh II six yeah I was pointing out as
soon as there's not pressure here I
could play e6
rook to c3 that would have caught me off
guard I don't have to take it the back
up these bishops are killers this night
I don't know if we could really call it
a night
it's definitely not a three-pointer I'm
a on the back rank there and from here
it's just gone
I'm able to cover any any color square
with these two guys around it with the
assistance of the e pawn makes things
easier
yeah I guess the last thing to check
here is did I what was what was the maid
exactly start capturing the Queen Queen
a Jay King e7 Bishop f6 I would have
been a nicer finish
just have to control e6 here here and
here his mate but okay got the Queen and
they resigned here before King takes
rook okay
well it's been a while for a rapid game
and he used to be classical this is now
a rapid time control 1510
I think I'll stick with 15 plus 10
increment it's a longer video but have
some more time to share my thoughts
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this one in the comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I'll
catch you soon that's all for now take
care bye
you